alors que l'europe et les états unis
sont en pleine deuxième vague de
qu'ovide la chine et ses voisins
asiatiques repartent de l'avant creusant
un peu plus encore l'écart avec les
économies occidentales
avec cette crise l'europe est elle
condamnée à décrocher de la croissance
mondiale pourquoi est il plus difficile
pour nous européens de nous en sortir
on voit ce cas tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir
jacques bonsoir c'est fini alors jacques
pendant que nous on lisait on est un
petit peu englué il n'y a pas d'autre
mot dans leur confinement la chine elle
evans a déjà tourné la page de
l'épidémie et oui c'est fini
la crise sanitaire la base c'est du
passé ou presque et dire c'est pas vrai
que pour la chine menace est vrai aussi
pour des pays comme taiwan 2 vietnam ou
la corée alors il faut comprendre que
ces pays ils ont réagi de manière
indifférente à la médiane en régie les
pays européens et ce qui fait qu'il
semble épargner en particulier par cette
fameuse deuxième vague que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
le résultat c'est évidemment que leur
économie ont beaucoup moins souffert de
l'épidémie et surtout qu'elles
reprennent leurs activités beaucoup plus
vite que nous rien le traité qui a été
signé le 15 novembre dernier vous savez
ce fameux vers ce pays où ce partenariat
économique régionale globale et d'un
indicateur aussi de comment les choses
sont en train d'évoluer
alors la question évidemment qu'on se
pose tous est ce que ces pays honte
appliquer des mesures plus ou moins
sévères que nous face à la pandémie
alors une question intéressante c'est
fini cela dépend en fait on voit quand
on compare un petit peu les mesures qui
ont été prises par ces pays que certains
ont eu et ont pris des mesures qui
étaient très faibles d'autres ont pris
des mesures qui aidé par contre
extrêmement sévère on voit par exemple
que à taiwan les mesures ont été légères
mais que en corée au vietnam encore et
encore plus en chine évidemment
eh bien on est en présence de mesures
qui ont été extrêmement sévère pourtant
et là haut il faut regarder un petit peu
sur l'axé vertical du graphique et bien
ces mesures ont beaucoup moins
détériorés l'activité économique que les
mesures qui ont été prises chez nous en
fait
ce qui est en cause c'est le fait que
ces mesures ont souvent été très
différentes
ainsi les différents pays asiatiques ont
fermé leurs frontières
ce que la france en particulier s'est
refusé à faire pour des raisons qui sont
essentiellement idéologique
le résultat c'est que nous avons connu
un recul de notre activité qui est
beaucoup plus important
alors jacques comment cela se traduit-il
sur l'activité précisément stéphanie
selon que l'activité plutôt industriels
ou plutôt dans les services évidemment
il ya des différences on l'a vu par
exemple dans le graphique précédent avec
le cas de la russie dont l'économie est
essentiellement centré sur l'industrie
mais si on prend en compte uniquement
justement c'est cette question de
l'industrie et des on voit que l'encore
la chute de la production en chine
elle a été plutôt plus faible que dans
les autres pays et que l la chine s'est
redressée beaucoup plus rapidement par
exemple quatre mois après le pic de la
crise la chine avait retrouvé son niveau
de décembre 2019 alors que en août c'est
à dire quatre mois après le pic d'avril
aucun des pays que ce soit les
etats-unis la russie ou la france même
man n'avait retrouvé plus de 95% de ce
fameux niveau
ainsi la france a été le pays le plus
affecté et la russie ils paient le moins
souffert d'une certaine manière mais on
voit très bien que quatre mois après la
crise ils sont approximativement au même
niveau mais pourquoi c'est forcément la
question qu'on a envie de vous poser
jacques alors ya plusieurs raisons
d'abord il faut dire que en chine
l'épidémie a surtout été concentrées
dans la province du hubei
là où se trouve la ville de one les
mesures de confinement qui ont été
prises localement on était très très
sévères elles l'ont été moins dans le
reste du pays et donc l'activité
économique a un petit peu moins souffert
après ce qui est frappant c'est que la
chine a quasiment interrompu ses
communications avec le reste du monde
le transport aérien a encore aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs il faut le souligner n'est
qu'à 5 ou 6 % de ce qu'il était avant
l'épidémie et on observe la même chose
avec le taiwan avec taiwan la corée ou
avec le vietnam tous ces pays ont fermé
au caire ont mis en place des règles de
14 n extrêmement stricte sur les
personnes qui souhaitait y entrer et
d'ailleurs il en va de même pour la
russie alors quelles seront les
conséquences de cette situation
alors il est absolument évident c'est
fini que non seulement les pays qui sont
autour de la chine a été moins affectée
mais surtout qu'il semble se relever et
bien pluie et on va le voir d'ailleurs
sur un graphique on voit là que si on
regarde les taux de croissance tels
qu'ils étaient estimés avant la deuxième
vague parce que ce sont des calculs qui
ont été faits et qui ont été faits au
mois de septembre
et on voit que l'écart se creuse de
manière tout à fait spectaculaire entre
les pays développés comme la france
l'allemagne le japon et des etats-unis
d'un côté et la chine de l'aude
alors bien évidemment avec les
conséquences économiques du continent
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
eh bien on va avoir cet écart se creuse
et encore plus les pays qui ont su
préserver en partie leurs économies
comme l'allemagne ou les états unis
seront peut-être un petit peu moins
affecté que ceux qui ont plus ou moins
arrêter leurs activités mais ils
prendront un aussi un retard important
sur la chine est globalement sur toutes
les aiguilles sud est ce enfin la cause
de 19 et bien elle a été révélatrice de
tendances lourdes qui sont présentes en
réalité depuis dix à vingt ans alors
concrètement cette manière bien c'est à
dire que ça fait des années
en réalité que les pays européens que la
zone euro accumulent du retard dans son
développement
la croissance moyenne de la zone euro a
été l'une des plus faibles du monde
depuis l'institution de l'euro et là on
le voit sur ce graphique aussi on voit
que nous allons être pour les prochaines
années en récession pour plusieurs
années alors que les pays émergents dont
les pays d'asie évidemment il est en
particulier eux
eh bien ils vont continuer à se
développer extrêmement rapidement même
la russie va faire mieux que la zone
euro dans ses prochaines années alors
essentiellement deux raisons à cela
il y a le fait que l'euro
joue le rôle d'un espèce d'étouffoir à
la croissance mais il ya aussi le fait
que nous sommes en fait spectateurs
autour de lui d'une croissance qui tend
à se développer essentiellement dans la
zone asie-pacifique qui est en train de
devenir le pôle de croissance mondiale
seulement ce pôle va être sous contrôle
chinois
et c'est ici que prend tout son sens
l'accord de libre échange qui a été
signé à pékin le 15 novembre
le rcp et qui avec lui s'éteint le point
intéressant y compris des pays qui ont
des relations politiques plutôt
difficile avec le film donc en clair
jacques ça veut dire que le coleader 19
c'est un petit peu la fin de l'europe
telle que nous la connaissons
et oui c'est un risque si on n'y fait
rien si on ne prend pas des mesures le
retard que nous sommes en train de
prendre et qu'il sera cumulatif or ce
retard va nous mettre dans une situation
difficile
le jour où nous aurons à négocier avec
la chine l'exemple du ralliement de
l'australie ou de la nouvelle zélande à
l'accord chinois doit nous servir de
leçon
si nous continuons sur ce chemin ce sera
la satellisation politique mais aussi la
satellisation économie seulement la
question qui se pose c'est pour nous
combler ce retard avec le carcan de
l'euro bien ça on peut malheureusement
au bout de merci jacques peut-être que
certains entendront votre avertissement
merci à vous